[Musique]
une enfant tu seras bientôt donner
elle survivra
et à travers elles t'aligner prospérera
[Musique]
je tiens pas être que abdou part appelé
chacun d'eux
leur usage
guitare et vient d'être pose question
si tu avais fait des choix différents
un coin de vie aurait été elle ressemble
et grand mère qu'est ce qu'il ya
si quelqu'un vous sollicitez qui était
votre foyer et venir vivre avec lui pour
commencer une nouvelle vie nous
acceptons
rien ne nous oblige à rester dans
l'ombre de nos familles
[Musique]
si pour cela il faut que je travaille à
mon arraché les ongles
je veux que cet enfant est tous pourvus
[Musique]
tu te dis d'autant plus mal
à montbard
[Musique]